the Liberals are seething
over
Elon Musk taking their blue check
privileges away well he's actually not
taking their blue check privileges away
he's just going to charge them eight
dollars a month for it
and you can tell it's all the art of the
deal Steph he first he comes out he says
I'm going to fire three quarters of the
staff and everyone freaks out about that
and he's probably gonna fire a much
lower number but whatever he fires it'll
seem like a compromise because he
started out at this insane negotiating
position so he opened up he said I'm
going to charge people 20 bucks a month
for their blue checks
then everyone freaked out about it and
he said okay it'll only be eight bucks a
month but that was probably his number
to begin with and he says I'm gonna
charge you eight bucks a month if you
want to keep your blue check if you want
to get special privileges with your blue
check because uh I'm I'm going to
democratize the blue checks and AOC in
particular lost it she goes LMAO at a
billionaire earnestly trying to sell
people on the idea that free speech is
actually an eight dollar a month
subscription plan
Elon Musk I love the Elon Musk AOC
dynamic
where he'll say hey stop flirting with
me come on I'm shy don't hey come on any
so your response here he goes your
feedback's appreciated now pay eight
dollars
because it's not he's not charging eight
dollars for free speech he's charging
eight dollars for what he's referred to
as the Lords and peasants model of
Twitter that has prevailed until now
which is that if you're on Twitter and
you have a blue check I I am one of the
the Blessed few who has a blue check and
it's true you get Amplified a lot more
you you have a much wider reach it's
considered not just a way to verify your
identity which is what it was supposed
to be but it's considered a mark of
prestige which this is why it was really
strange back when uh in 2016 or 2017 the
Liberals took away Richard Spencer the
white identitarian political activist
they took away his blue check mark his
verification badge
well if it's a verification badge why
would they take it away did he stop
being Richard Spencer no they took it
away because they knew that it was a
mark of prestige and they wanted to take
that Prestige away from him and so Elon
Musk is coming in and saying everyone
should get The Prestige
and the Liberals the Democrats
ironically they say no we don't want
that
is it about the eight bucks Elon also
replied to AOC with a picture from her
campaign website where she is selling a
purple sweatshirt just a cheap
purple sweatshirt for 58 dollars he's
like is eight dollars so hard for you
also AOC drove a Tesla I don't know if
she still does but she the woman
famously owned a Tesla okay so she's
doing very well and she clearly likes
Elon musk's products
but it's it in a way it is just a
perfect representation of the stakes in
this election which is the Democrats are
telling you that if you don't support
them you hate democracy meanwhile they
do everything they possibly can to
undermine democracy
whether we're talking about trade deals
whether we're talking about immigration
whether we're talking about election day
or whether we're talking about your blue
check mark on Twitter
Democrats are the party of oligarchy
maybe they always were
they certainly are now the Republicans
are the party of democracy
For Better or For Worse that's the
situation that we are in right now and
many people have perceived that and
that's why people who not that long ago
would have called themselves Democrats
and who really care about democracy and
they and their anti-establishment it's
why they are flocking in droves to the
Republicans it's why the Democrats are
trying so hard to suppress their votes
far from seeing the the GOP split
or the women vote split or anything like
that you're actually seeing it all come
together and you're seeing it come
together in a really crucial place in
Arizona so in Arizona Blake Masters is
running for the Senate against Mark
Kelly Mark Kelly is a rubber stamp for
Chuck Schumer and he's a Democrat but
he's got an interesting personal story
he's an astronaut his wife Gabby
Giffords was shot at a political event
and she had to leave Congress and then
he runs and he he enters the Senate and
so he's got a good personal story even
though he's an absolutely terrible
Senator Blake Masters is running in many
ways as an avatar of the new right he's
not just reciting all the same stupid
platitudes that we've heard for the last
15 years from the squishy loser
Republicans he's talking about real
things he thinks that the 2020 election
was stolen okay his words not mine don't
take me off YouTube but that's what he
thinks he says that in America it should
be a top priority of our politics to
make it to create the political
condition such that people can raise a
family on one income really really great
stuff talking in explicitly pro-family
to traditional conservative terms I
absolutely love that
on and on we've interviewed Blake on
this show I'm really supportive of his
campaign he he was
behind a little bit in the polls we'll
see it's going to be a real nail biter
but he got great news because the
libertarian candidate in that race Mark
Victor just dropped out and urged his
supporters to vote for Masters really
good news now
one thing that's unfortunate about the
way that the Democrats have rigged our
system in the last few years is that
they've taken election day and turned it
into election months in some cases
election two months there's widespread
mail-in votes so the question is how
many people have already voted for Mark
Victor
I don't know the exact rules in Arizona
so it might not be as bad as it is in
some states the other problem is Mark
Victor will be on the ballot so he
didn't drop out early enough to not be
on the ballot uh which is too bad that
would have helped Blake a lot more
but in any case good on Mark for for
dropping out
he says after a discussion with him I
believe it is in the best interests of
freedom and peace to withdraw my
candidacy and enthusiastically support
Black Masters for U.S Senate I intend to
assist in any way reasonably possible to
elect Blake
great line and that's how Republicans
should be thinking and not just
Republicans it's how moderates and even
Center life people should be thinking
think about the people who were on the
left
who in recent years seemed to be
supporting the Republicans more than the
Democrats I think about really prominent
people Joe Rogan
I think probably Bill Maher
I think about uh people like Elon Musk
Elon Musk was on the left for most of
his life he seems to be much more on the
right right now
normal people who say look I might not
agree with everything this candidate
wants I might not agree even with their
basic way of viewing the world but I
know that something is just really
really corrupt something is really
really wrong something is really really
incompetent about the Democrat party
it's a it's ironic that that the
Democrats are making this play right now
to say regardless of what you think
about the issues you've got to vote for
us because we're the Defenders of
democracy I think it's totally the
opposite I think it's the opposite in
reality and I think it's the opposite in
the perception of the people I think a
lot of people who don't like the
Republicans generally or who are not
don't consider themselves all that
conservative they're looking at the
system right now and they're saying wow
the Democrats pose a legitimate threat
to democracy they're rigging our
election system they're calling half the
country terrorists and fascists they're
sicking their Jack booted thugs on their
political opponents like Donald Trump at
Mar-A-Lago they're calling parents at
school boards domestic terrorists
they're trying to transgender our kids
against our will they're trying to
they're just they're such a threat to
our traditional way of life
such a threat to our rights such a
threat to our liberties
that we can't vote for the Democrats
we've got to vote for
the Republicans
now I don't know very much about polling
so I'm going to invite on a master
pollster Robert kahaly to tell me what I
should know going into midterm elections
the rest of the show is continuing now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]